si vous deviez faire votre liste vers
noël vous vous demanderiez quoi aux
palmistes à mouy ameline et hélicoptères
[Rires]
j'ai rien qui me vient en tête ballon
c'est vrai ce que j'aime le père noël
j'aimerais juste qu'ils me donnent une
chose l'amour l'amitié voilà l'amitié
l'amour des autres voilà est juste la
fraternité
et la paix sur la terre ouais on dirait
si sa
perte à 10 h j'ai travaillé ce week-end
à et il est venu à la maison chaque
février vers cette date il a joué au
ping pong contre monfils il a pris une
tannée il a perdu deux matchs contre
mons et le cema fils marc et magnésium
j'ai défoncé
c'est vraiment du coup j'ai lu
aujourd'hui il a pris date il a très
bien joué il a très bien joué vous avez
un petit pari de dit bâle iii aboient je
serai
je ne manquerai pas nous faire imprimer
le ferai avec grand plaisir voilà c'est
bien beau et gilles verdez alors j'ai
été très content parce que facto a
accepté une invitation à dîner qui
commet désinsérer vous êtes l'équipe de
picard
et donc sa première fois qu'elle est
vraiment mais c'est jamais gagné ça va
très bien alors votre couple il est pas
un peu chelou sont des collègues c'est
le seul mec il est que sa veuve depuis
15 ans ils n'ont qu'à l'accepter mouche
avec toi alors j'attends mais ça s'est
super bien passé oui mais ça a dégénéré
au fil de la soirée ah oui parce que
j'ai trouvé que c'est un restaurant
africain génial tout se passait bien
j'ai trouvé que des gens s'approchent un
peu de notre table et donc d'elle non et
j'ai un peu pété les plombs et à l'ats
péter les plombs elle m'a dit tu deviens
une racaille et au sahara ici
la fin oui il arrête
zemmour c'est quand tu es quand j'ai dit
aux gars arrêter comme ça je m'énerve
tout comme si je
montiel fait le gars vous allez faire
fatou donc la fa tout est là là là et là
il ya un gars qu'est ce qu'il fait là il
commence à la regarder à vouloir
s'installer auprès d'elle puis honte à
tulle à 12tu la touche tu pas pas dans
la gueule
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le mas fait c'était pour qu'il
donne envie sans quoi il ya une ombre
j'ai eu une embrouille ils étaient 4
j'ai appelé le patron fatoma diar es tu
laisses tomber et à la fin elle était
tellement énervée elle m'a dit écoute je
dire gilles à la sortie de ce restaurant
ou dans un prochain restaurant il ya un
mec qui va t'attendre à la sortie qui va
te mettre un pain dans la gueule et tu
l'aura bien cherché et je tâche est vrai
c'est vrai bah non c'est toujours cool
ils sont elles la pensée comme est
vraiment mais pourquoi qui s'est passé
premier parce que je trouve que il la
pensée de trop près voulait s'installer
c'est un récent et des tables analysé
des billets et donc il y avait une table
de 2 ils ont voulu se mettre à quatre il
a collé un peu en plus celui elle était
en face de moi celui qui est elle a
commencé à la regarder il lui souriait
j'ai dû lui dire mais arrête de sourire
à qui tout sourit donc franchement ça a
dégénéré
mais le reste on est génial et ça
franchement dégénéré mouassa des âmes sa
patte c'est selon moi si ça continue
comme ça j'y vais plus haut restant
voilà c'est ce que je lui ai dit elle
m'a dit tant mieux de façon gérer plus
jamais avec toi ici au volant et elle a
meilleur goût que lui mais quand on est
allé à l'élection miss machin mois nous
en juin dernier elle était folle de rage
du choix qu'il avait fait sinon les fins
de ses comptes
on annonce avec mon ami marc massie
vous avez fini a surgi desailly wayne
middaugh pas tout je suis souvent
d'accord avec elle mais ce bracelet deux
contrôles j allais que je vous ai pas
tout ouais merci c'est quoi là aussi
j'aime les fruits secs
appris que sa femme l'avait alors et moi
ce week end mais que des choses dont
vous avez rien à faire c'est de jouer au
badminton il ya encore des gens qui
m'ont dit cyril avait promis qu'il
viendrait jouer
voilà le lundi c'est pas ton jour
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est alors évident
donc j'ai bien joué mais vous avez rien
ça c'est pas du paddle et après j'ai
commencé à regarder les boules de noël
partout comment on va regarder des
cadeaux vous êtes sûr que c'était bien
des boules de noël parce que c'est
monsieur brille est d'accord c'est faire
la différence encore